agora um corr inevitável entre irmão é
briga irmão briga por tudo irmão briga
por qualquer coisa principalmente por
nada nada nada briga começa a brigado
nada por exemplo já prestou atenção do
teu irmão tudo que ele vê feio parece
contigo um dia tava passando no SBT Eu
lembro que fosse hoje Corcunda de notri
dame eu tranquilo caminhando na sala ó
eu entro tu na televisão eu corri quando
eu fui ver o cara aí eu comecei mãe o tá
diendo que eu pareço com ccum de nó de
dama mãe rapaz cara tu não coa de de
ficar implicando com teu irmão não a a
mãe começa a botar qualidade na coisa
feia que teu irmão falou que tu parecia
PR ver se se a menisa situação não meu
filho corcun not Drum olha corcun de not
Drum trabalha ganha dinheiro ele toca o
sino da igreja olha P ele é forte hum
forte forte aí foi que eu fiquei mais
triste ainda porque ela não falou que eu
não parecia o corcun notri Dame sou
comidão